Oh my God, I'm so excited to speak with you.
I have had such appreciation
and respect for you for so many years.
Same, same.
I've been watching you and your beautiful fiance,
and beautiful daughter,
and we'll get into "Encanto" in a minute.
Thank you.
And I was watching you
at the Academy Awards
and the emotionality is right there on the surface,
and it is about family.
But is it true that you still live with your family?
It's complicated.
I love this, tell us.
So I'm a Latino man,
the end.
(Drew laughing)
(audience clapping)
It's very simple, Drew.
Drew, it's very simple.
We believe in family, you know?
And when we came to the United States, back in '93, '94,
the sacrifice that my parents had to bring us to America,
what they gave up just for us to be here.
So to answer your question,
why does my family live so close,
aka in the same property?
I knew that I was gonna have children,
'cause that's what I wanted in my life.
I wanted to be a father.
And so I had an opportunity and I went for it.
I bought this couple of acres in LA.
And as soon as I was finishing up "'70s Show,"
I was like, "I don't know whenever I'm gonna make
this kind of money again,
so I think I'm gonna buy something that'll last me forever."
And I bought this property.
I saw my kids running around there when I was 26.
And then, I had an opportunity to buy the neighbor's house
that only has like trees and bushes
in between mine and that house.
So when I bought that house, I gave it to my mom, you know?
(audience clapping)
Uh!
So my mom is...
Get the machete out and just buy that property
and knock that, you know,
with all due respect to the greenery, make way.
Make way, make way, because I also knew
that I think that I subliminally knew
that at some point when I had kids
I would have like a built-in babysitter, you know?
100%!
And then, for sure
it became that.
My mom has like shifts, you know, in the day.
She walks through the little revolving door
in between our properties.
She picks up the baby at 10.
She takes her, go has breakfast and lunch with her,
brings her back.
It's pretty incredible to have that.
And, you know, so yeah,
I do have my family living in the same property.
What did your fiance think when she was like,
"Oh, wow, so you're are all living together"?
Was she like, "I'm in, I'm on board"?
Or was she like, "Oh, wow, that's not my life experience"?
What was her attitude towards it?
She's half Mexican.
So she was half like, "I love it,"
but then like, "forever?"
But I think it was, you know,
we were very intentional about everything we were doing
when we got together then.
We knew that when we got together
that a family was a possibility.
And as soon as we started doing the math,
we're like, "Oh, mom next door?
Absolutely," like that.
And now I have loved you, obviously, as a creator too.
"Encanto" huge, won the Academy Award!
(audience cheering)
Thank you.
Congratulations!
When your beautiful daughter
watches the film.
Don't even get me started.
Does she recognize your voice?
'Cause you play the father, the patriarch.
Yeah, so she's 14 months.
She recognizes the music now and she's just loving it.
But speaking of, what triggered me,
was that I feel like I subliminally have been making things
and creating things in my career
and banking them as an archive.
So when she's old enough,
she arrives to a well of content
that looks and sounds like her,
and that also sees the relativity
of the humanity of this family that's timeless.
But yeah, I love it.
I'm excited.
Well, wait until she enjoys
all the years of "That '70s Show" too,
which was I never missed an episode.
It's my favorite!
I'm gonna delay
the allowing of that one.
Yeah, when she's older.
But then there's "NCIS".
You're special agent Nick Torres.
(audience clapping)
Thank you.
I know that you also have "Zorro"
in development at Disney+.
Yeah, can you believe it?
Are you gonna be able to maintain all of this?
I mean, this is a lot on your plate.
It is a lot on my plate,
but I'm up for the challenge.
You come to a point in your life where, you know,
we talk about this Mount Everest
and I think "Zorro" is one of those, right?
I love you as Zorro so much, I can't even handle it.
Get it, hurry!
Hurry, hurry, hurry.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
I'll tell you that this will be a Zorro
for this generation,
and it'll be incredibly thoughtful with its origin story,
and it'll be grounded in authenticity.
Well, I trust it very much in your hands.
(upbeat music)